[Musique]
une intrusion d'une violence sans
précédent
après avoir escaladé l'enceinte du
capitole les partisans de donald trump
ne brisent les vitres et envahissent le
bâtiment ils répondaient à l'appel du
président républicain à marcher vers le
congrès nous exigeons de la part du
congrès écarte tous les habitants y
avait sur facebook un groupe qui
s'appelait red state cessession qu'ils
étaient suivis par huit mille personnes
est déjà dans ce groupe
eh bien on envisager l'assaut du câble
idole on se passait même des adresses
des adresses de juges des adresses
demande du parlement qui était désigné
comme des ennemis de l'amérique dont que
vous le voyez c'est quand même assez
grave et ce groupe a seulement étaient
désactivées et bien mercredi matin hier
matin notre démocratie sur itunes sans
précédent comme jamais auparavant une
attaque contre la citadelle de la
liberté capitole une attaque entre les
représentants du peuple
la police du capitole et non sens de la
loi un assaut contre les engagements est
consacrée du pays soit le peu de chacun
je veux être clair le scènes de chaos au
capitole oui on ne représente pas
l'amérique
il est devenu le symbole de l'intrusion
au capitole des militants pro trump
depuis hier soir les photos et vidéos de
jake angeli torse nu casque à cornes et
bonnet en peau de bête sur la tête font
le tour des réseaux sociaux
l'homme de 32 ans est un membre bien
connu de kyo hanon une mouvance
complotistes proche de l'extrême droite
là il est dans les gradins mais la photo
la plus dingue c'est celle ci on le voit
en train de poser devant le siège de
mike pence le vice président des états
unis
laura est allé lui demander les raisons
qui l'ont poussé à faire ce geste fou
j'ai fait une prière à l'intérieur pour
qu'ils bannissent le mal de ce monde et
qu'il rétablisse les divines créatures
de dieu dans nos vies est à nouveau au
sénat
voilà c'est vraiment le gendre idéal
ce matin donald trump a admis la fin de
son mandat dans un communiqué et annoncé
une transition en bonne et due forme
il a cependant répété son désaccord
total avec le résultat d'élections et a
dit qu'il continuerait le combat
il s'exprime par communiqué parce que
depuis hier soir ses comptes twitter et
facebook ont été bloqués et twitter
explique que si 30 ne supprime pas lui
même ses derniers messages des plus
virulents et bien son compte restera
bloqué un peu plus tard facebook a
emboîté le pas de twitter en suspendant
la page de donald trump pour 24 heures
cette fois idem sur instagram décision
saluée par les anti trump 1 qui appelle
d'ailleurs les réseaux à bloquer donald
trump jusqu'à l'investiture de joe biden
le 20 janvier
mais encore une fois on peut
s'interroger sur le pouvoir de ses
plateformes dans le trou le croissant ou
l' angoisse plonge des peuples
le risque grandit tous les jours que les
événements et chats au raisonnable et
que les pires catastrophes puisse être
déclenchée par des fanatiques des fous
ou des ambitieux en guise de réponse
il n'a mis qu'une terre nous foncent
dessus
quand quelqu'un il n'hésite pas à nous
frapper
voilà tout ce que mon petit surnom sur
la route c'est la douleur que ça me
correspond bien cherche moi tu vas me
trouvais tu vas comprendre la douleur
jacques weber françois morel françois
berléand ou encore richard berry 200
artistes au total se disent prêts à se
faire vacciner dans les colonnes du
journal le parisien
il tenait ou et que ce vaccin serait un
gps humains contenterait de d'infiltrer
une puce on sait où pour moi c'est ça et
pas que pour mon arrivée vous le touchez
pas beaucoup de personnes voilà on
essaye effectivement pourquoi à cause du
mot c'est je veux dire on est serrés
c'est une intuition c'est une convection
vous avez lu ça arrange et de revues
sans qu'il fût gg pas dire on est bon
vous savez quand on est pas des
scientifiques on n'est pas des gens
connus on est des quidams et donne moi
la date de la guerre 14 18
[Musique]
si je me trompe
14 18
trente lots il a 25 ans n années 2000
il sort de l'école moi j'ai 28 ans
aujourd'hui limite ggm pied dans la
tombe donc je ne comprends pas lui tout
cela rappelle plus sa date ou ça vous
êtes en train de nous dire il y a un
plan alors j'aurai le savoir par qui il
est décidé pour introduire une puce à
l'intérieur de 60 millions de français
pardonnez moi
ou dit doudou lyonnais tente quand on
tient une théorie pareil faut quand même
avoir quelques éléments d'information
beaucoup à nouveau la voix parlée on est
beaucoup à se poser des questions mais
poser des grottes se pose des questions
c'est étrange au coran d'accord at
roduit runes puce sciemment d'abord dans
quel but qui décide de sa demain la
france va commémorer les 25 ans de la
mort du président françois mitterrand
pour en parler voici l'ancien président
françois mitterrand françois hollande
[Musique]
j'ai dit françois mitterrand c'est la
même chose moi je dis c'est une
mascarade dans ma vidéo du 18 mars au
début vous quand je dis vous et les
médias on a eu un bang au lin et une
chauve-souris qu'on fournit clé excusez
moi du terme
et ça nous a donné excusez moi un noir
c'est ce qui a été dit à la télé n'est
donc pas s'il vous plaît non mais c'est
ce qui a été dit à la télé je ne suis
pas un menteur
non les relations sexuelles entre le
malade alors bat là-bas c'est elliott
c'est mon tracteur elliott quand je l'aï
vu je trouvais qu'il avait vraiment une
tête à s'appeler elliott jeu j'ai besoin
de bichonner parce que ma mine de rien
c'est bah c'est mon compagnon aussi quoi
c'est lui qui me transporte partout
c'est lui qui me tient chaud la nuit
c'est lui qui me tient compagnie c'est
lui qui met coupons je vais pas bien
j'ai fait des petits gratuit que je vais
prendre sa petite douche mais c'est que
du bonheur
des films et laver la semaine total une
grosse mare dans la vie d'un jeune maman
entre café pour se donner de l'argent
n'achète pas la flamme des jo de sotchi
dans les sondages étaient touchés lundi
laurent chez vous je m'habille merci moi
et moi et moi c'est tout cas merci c'est
bon